another controversial topic the new head
of the Police Federation John Apter has
confessed that police are wasting too
much time investigating trivial social
media roles instead of solving serious
crime
this comes soon after South Yorkshire
police used this social media account to
encourage the public to report what they
honestly called non crime hate speech
yes you heard that correctly hunting
pre-crime as if from Tom Cruise's
futuristic film Minority Report the
police are now interested in your non
criminal speech meanwhile violent crime
has increased by 18 percent from the
year before while the number of criminal
charges faced by offenders is falling
with legislation on the books that
defines hate speech as hinging on a mere
perception even the perception from a
third party police are bound therefore
by a policy that forces them to pay
attention to policing speech at the
expense of policing actual crime this is
what happens when justice becomes more
about politics than about policing and
with elected police commissioner's
worried about their next election
victory pandering to the mob may now
sadly have become a policing priority
[Music]
I'm amazed by some of the things you've
said yeah pre-crime non crime hate
that's a direct quote I mean given that
something like 48% of crimes they have
to close the book on the crimes without
identifying a suspect that is absolutely
scandalous I was all I mean even before
you said that I was I've been concerned
for a while about the way that historic
sexual accusations have actually soaked
up so much police crime you know online
crime fraud and all the rest is it
because cop is like sitting around I
don't get it before we go to film from
the Home Secretary on on why they're
focusing so much on online we all know
that the so-called traditional crime is
down by a third since 2010 but there are
all sorts of other crimes which are
being reported
more than ever before and this of course
is putting huge demands on policing like
hate crimes and child sexual abuse the
threat from terrorism
of course we sadly seen has escalated
and involved and we also know that there
are more more victims of online crime in
fact you're more likely to be a victim
online crime than offline crime I'd like
to see the police focus on terrorism and
violent crime and burglary get this to a
point okay when you're looking at an
enemy just full of soldiers point of
view when you look at an enemy you want
all the intelligence and everything you
can gather under one blanket so you can
make your decisions where the police are
losing here is that not backed up to go
out and do their jobs properly and
they're almost battered into the end of
the cage they don't they haven't got the
right kit and equipment for the job as
far as I'm concerned they haven't got
the money for training they need proper
backup okay they are spending time
online and rightly so because prevention
is better than a cure and if you can
identify problems that are emanating
online you can stop them from spilling
over into the wider path or do you
respect I think you're presenting first
of all the idea that there's real crime
which is violent crime and burglary and
then there's online crime which is a
proper quiet there are more victims of
online crime now than there are victims
of crime so that is serious crime
secondly you're presenting this is this
kind of mutually exclusive either the
police catch burglars and rapists or
they look at hate speech online or not
the region we are Dean as decrease in
the policing of violent crime which I
agree is very serious yeah it's because
look at this statistic police funding
fell by almost a fifth presenting this
was somehow because the police have lost
and are doing all with for crime you
know let me make this very clear this is
not Elise's fault the police haven't
lost it because I began by quoting the
head of the Police Federation himself
complaining about it so kindly go and
tell him he doesn't know what he's
talking about the problem here as I made
very clear in my introduction if you're
listening I won't comment not to hear
what I said
the problem is politics not policing of
where the problem is the policy in place
both on legislation which obliges police
to investigate things that there's a
perception were offensive even if by a
third party and then the second problem
is the elected police commissioner such
as the elected police commissioner of
South Yorkshire police who defended this
this is the specific tweet if you look
at the specific wording it says please
report lawn crime hate incidents and
when asked about this South Yorkshire
Police doubled down so if you look at
the statement that they made in response
when asked in explicitly says the police
can only prosecute when the law is
broken but we also want to know about
non crime hate incidents and it says
these may be often and I cited an
example if you cut me up in the road and
I cut and I suggest we don't know who
your father was the guy said he wants
that reported seriously that will be
happening in the streets of to support
totally support make sure we don't need
the whole quote let's just tell you that
the Police Federation Chairman arguments
over the control and argument some of
the facts are 9 percent of crimes result
within a charge or summons that's down
something 11 percent okay that's because
I because my car got broken into and
everything in it got smashed and we all
complete and they took my coat my wallet
and my teeth we called the police and
they were like no we don't really vest
those kind of times anymore are you
seriously trying
offensive now is that is that now the
definition of a non crime hate speech
their own tweet because I found it
offensive no right to be offended but
should I report their own tweet to them
this is how silly this is my
interpretation double down my invitation
is they're saying this is an area we
have no jurisdiction to do anything
about we can't prosecute or investigate
we thought we would like to filled up a
picture to help us understand the
environment of hate so that when crimes
happen it's in a context that's
basically there is loads of evidence
that sophisticated policing comes out of
intelligence gathering in fact it's
old-fashioned policing they get with the
head of the Police Federation he's upset
they're wasting time on this probably
because he's listening people
sensationalizing it like Yuma I'm sure
you know these tears sometimes within
intelligence those things that lead on
and things that don't yes do not mean
and the remote control is a good example
broken they have to investigate the
crime if the new door has been broken
there's no company the problems are law
itself as well non quite like so so it's
all about hate speech it's even cut it
comes down to a perception even by a
third party which is where they're
getting this non-crime stuff from
they're saying if it feels offensive
report it because the legislation is
that vague